is a residential neighborhood in the
town of pavlograd it's about 70 miles
from the Russian front line and you can
see the devastation from this missile
attack overnight a Russian installed
official said it was part of an attack
that was aiming at an ammunitions Depot
and a railway line not far from here but
I can tell you this is smack dab in the
middle of a residential neighborhood
it's a second time in three nights the
Russians have Unleashed a missile
barrage in this country Ukrainian
officials say 15 of 18 missiles that
were headed toward key were shot down in
fact all of the ones that were headed to
the Capitol were intercepted these they
believe were launched cruise missiles
launched from Russian bombers and it's
exactly the kind of air defense systems
the ukrainians have been begging for
something to protect the cities protect
neighborhoods like this and to protect
Ukrainian forces ahead of this expected
Ukrainian spring offensive that we're
expecting any day now